des assises de tchernobyl se tenait hier
et aujourd'hui à chambéry pour attirer
l'attention sur les risques de
catastrophes dans tous les pays de
l'ancien bloc de l'est 18 centrales
nucléaires à risque sont dans le
collimateur des organisations
internationales
joseph dans la pierre centrale du
kazakhstan
cinquante incidents la même année un
incendie il ya deux ans près de saint
pétersbourg incident sur le réacteur
numéro 3 un nuage radioactif s'échappe
bulgarie la centrale n'en finit pas de
s'arrêter et de redémarrer une liste qui
fait peur et qui ne cesse de s'alourdir
le souvenir de tchernobyl pèse sur les
centrales en ruine des pays de l'est
les accidents n'ont jamais été aussi
nombreux
des bombes à retardement il y en a 18
dans les pays de l'ancien bloc
soviétique
sur cette carte les cinq qui clignote
sont les centrales qu'il serait urgent
de fermer quant aux autres elles
pourraient être sauvées remise aux
normes
à condition que l'argent arrive à
condition que l'occident prennent en
compte le risque potentiel qui jusqu'ici
a été négligée il y à un danger
certainement
il ne faut pas mettre tous les réacteurs
des pays de l'est dans le même paquet je
crois qu'actuellement le poids chaud
c'est tchernobyl des centrales
construites il ya plus de vingt ans
dangereux dès leur conception
aujourd'hui livrés à l'instabilité
politique au manque de personnel
qualifié à une maintenance inexistante
des centrales qui demande énormément
d'argent pour leurs modifications ou
même pour leur arrêt définitif
sans oublier que dans de nombreuses
régions on manque cruellement de
ressources énergétiques en bulgarie une
seule centrale fournit 50 % de
l'électricité
elle est pourtant parmi les plus
dangereuses